sí Bueno pues son estos que ya
mencionábamos no sin duda Bueno desde el
Salvador hasta Guatemala ha habido
dificultades que han llevado a la gente
o que han obligado en cierta forma a las
personas a migrar y y bueno en ciertos
casos particulares como es el caso de
Nicaragua como es el caso de Cuba de
Venezuela también tiene que ver los
regímenes políticos que están
instaurados en estos países no y pues
quizá las amenazas o la persecución
política que algunas personas han
seguido desde ahí en otros y una de las
razones principales de los últimos años
es la violencia la violencia
la violencia y las amenazas de muerte
por parte de grupos del crimen
organizado Y eso es una razón de huida
digamos otra vez desde el Salvador hasta
México Incluso en el caso mexicano es
importante mencionar que nosotros ya
teníamos un algo que el que le
llevábamos tasa cero es decir eran más
migrantes los que retornaban los que se
iban Y a partir de 2020 a 2021 2022 otra
vez vemos un repunte importante de la
migración mexicana y el principal motivo
de las personas mexicanas para Estados
Unidos que es la principal nacionalidad
de llegada por allá de nuevo que Repito
no lo veíamos hace una década es la
violencia y las amenazas por parte de
grupos del crimen organizado que pues
están apoderándose prácticamente de
muchos de sus pueblitos de sus lugares
en donde viven y Bueno pues hay amenazas
importantes y esto también lo vemos pues
en los en el caso de Centroamérica
también con amenazas por parte de las
maras pandillas y grupos criminales
entonces creo que eso es una de las
razones que hay que destacar Y pues el
resto también tiene que ver con pobreza
con falta oportunidades Bueno hasta el
cambio climático